[Music]
every night now the air raid sirens wail
and people Scramble for safety this war
is getting uglier as men women and
children cower for another night in the
Darkness
this is a place that is awaiting its
fate the United Nations is moving all
non-essential staff and their families
this group heading for the Border
on the roads to the South Ukrainian
armor rumbles to meet the growing threat
these troops advancing to reinforce the
defense of this region
inside the city there is an atmosphere
of paranoia and suspicion as rumors of
Russian spies circulate this man was
detained at gunpoints
and all the time roads and buildings are
being four to fight
this is a fight for the soul of this
country I'm here because I think that
everyone should unite in our efforts and
maybe I can't kill someone but I can
help in other way
these people want to fight but for now
will offer their support any way they
can the territorial defense has so many
volunteers they can't all join at once
there is a real sense of fear and
apprehension people are extremely scared
about what is happening to their country
but the levels of resistance here are
immense it seems that anyone who is able
to pick up a gun or fill up a sandbag is
coming forwards in defiance of the
Russian invasion
David has enrolled and is making Molotov
cocktails to defend his city is
[Music]
but as this brutal War descends further
it will be the innocent to Bear the
brunt of Russia's aggression there will
be many more frightening nights
Underground
Alex Rossi Sky News denipro